rewind this rewind this back to like 158
did you guys see that did you see that
wait hold on
look at this look Okay okay right here
it's right here
not tarantula although that's really
cool too miles as he's being like
tackled by these other Spider-Man
variants drops past this other one who
is not attacking him is that not the Tom
Holland Spider-Man from the MCU with the
white logo on the back I think I see
what you're saying
now the logo is a little different and
he doesn't have the red boots but like I
just yeah everyone
he's the only one who isn't like
jumping after miles he's just kind of
watching it he's not running he's not
sprinting around scrambling he's just
kind of like hey why are you attacking
that kid could this be could this be him
are we getting a Tom Holland cameo in
the Sony animated it's very interesting
that would be interesting oh my gosh
welcome Max new rock stars Spider-Man
across the spider versus Bridging the
full spiderverse together and it looks
like one of the members of Miguel
O'Hara's spider Force could be Tom
Holland Spider-Man around the MCU what
would it mean for Sony spider-verse and
for the MCU if this crossover actually
happens and what would Tom Holland Peter
Parker's role be on this Force an ally
to miles or a rival to miles
needles needles to say needles needles
for back to the people to say needless
to say it looks like it says needles in
the script are you sure this doesn't say
needles
needless looks like needles when you
ride it out noodles
this is like Berenstain
yeah this is truly inside Marvel it's
new Rockstar's weekly Marvel reaction
show and this week we are still trying
to unpack this Spider-Man across the
spider-verse trailer and how Sony might
be trying to reclaim the MCU Spider-Man
in a spider-verse plot to set up Peter
and Miles relationship going forward I'm
Eric Boss with me today is Jessica
Clemens and Mt Hello friends hello sir I
am still like so hyped from this trailer
it's been 24 hours since and like this
trailer has like made me so happy just
to like see like miles again and like
she's so he's so much taller like he's
so tough he's a big boy now
um and uh to see Gwen like oh my God all
these Spider-Man I'm so hyped yeah uh a
reminder to everyone that um Jessica and
Mt and I really like shared the Lord
divided and conquered with this one uh
Jess uh did the Easter egg breakdown by
the time you're watching this it's
probably already on the channel uh I did
a breakdown of the animation Styles and
some specific like inside jokes among
the animators that they snuck into this
mt's tackling the whole Multiverse logic
of this movie and now we've come back
together after going back to record what
was your experience yesterday I'm just
kind of curious to check back in with
you guys what was it like for you trying
to uh by yourself because I don't even
want to talk about it I
um uh Eric
has been doing this for a long time and
Eric is very good at finding these eggs
immediately uh me
he I as soon as the trailer dropped I
was so excited to see Jessica Drew but
also if you guys go back to our reaction
and see my face when we see that Citadel
of different Spider-Man my head exploded
but luckily with help from everyone from
new rock stars and an entire database of
different outfitted Spider-Mans on
Marvel fandom I was able to find a good
chunk just you saw yourself short I
think you are really good at this
because when I was like we just and I
got on the phone late uh yesterday
afternoon and we were just kind of like
talking about what we found and like I
gotta look at your script I was going
through it I'm like oh my God I didn't
see that I didn't see that I'm like Jess
had the way harder job to try to
identify all these suits and I'm like
thank God you were on this because I
gotta just be like oh look look at
miles's hands they Bob a little bit
because that means it's pretty straight
like that's that's not my breaks um I'm
I'm very interested in hearing mt's
breakdown individually both of your
breakdowns because every Spider-Man had
their own little kind of art style but
they said only six but I think there's
like 12 and then I'm just like how the
hell I I believe incursions are real and
they can still happen in the Sony
universe so that's why I'm so confused
on how everyone is able to just keep
going to different universes without it
being an issue and I don't know if you
tackle that Mt but if you do I need I I
do have like you know like a hunch but
like you know long story short I'm
pretty sure it's the bracelet
um
yeah because like um at the end of into
the spider-verse um uh what's called
Miguel's AI says that she Miguel's about
to be the first person to make an
autonomous Jump by himself and he he has
the bracelet so I think that the
bracelet keeps them from glitching out
in other universities oh
so that wouldn't be reason why miles is
the Troublemaker because he doesn't have
a bracelet
um this is not this inside Marvel
[Laughter]
but I oh my
oh my god well I mean it would kind of
mirror that metaphor of like college
like sneaking in the college party you
didn't get a bracelet to enter this uh a
keg party right you have to have a
bracelet
you're a minor that's not a bracelet you
got that at that Carnival across the
street miles is like just lick lick lick
your bracelet and then like take it off
and put it on my arm for a minute let me
get in there real quick
you don't understand how bad I need this
I'm trying to get some drinks
I gotta say last week we got to do this
in person I really miss like sharing a
table I know right it was so cool last
week it was so much fun no but this is
our natural feeling your body warmth was
so much fun during that group hug I
think about it all the time I run into
my diary that's so weird yeah
like every every time we passed empty in
the offices he's like remember how warm
you were yes because he peed his pants
he peed in the pool and then didn't tell
anyone and just said it's warm my pants
it's like oh this is so warm no it's
because I uh I'm I'm from Boston so like
any warmth I can get was uh much
appreciated
yeah when we all shared a swimming pool
Mt just kind of did that thing where he
like looked off in the distance was real
quiet for about like 48 seconds
he just created a nice little warm
pocket around himself oh yes but that's
all that's the best we can do during
these cold winter months is just find
your warmth right whatever it takes it's
fine if it's your own pee that's what I
say this is here I am talking like this
is a wookie leaks episode but it's not
it's a Marvel we we gotta get to some
actual Theory craft in here let's dive
in will Tom Holland Spider-Man appear in
across the spider verse I mean as we
stated before there is a Spider-Man
among Miguel O'Hara's fighter force that
looks a bit like Peter's suit from the
end of Far From Home the beginning of no
way home this is his London suit aka the
one that gets uh the gold coating and
the no way home final battle it has a
white logo on the back but the spiders
legs are longer in the logo here than
they are in the MCU version and this
Spider-Man's feet aren't red like uh the
Tom Holland one was but we do know that
Lord and Miller wanted to work in a Tom
Holland Cameo to the 2018 into the
spider-verse along with vocal kamias by
Toby McGuire and Andrew Garfield but
Sony told them uh to hold off and now
obviously we know why but now there's
really nothing stopping them from doing
that and across the spider versus an
arguably it makes even more sense now
that all those Spider-Man have crossed
over in the live action universe but Tom
Holland Peter has a new suit at the end
of no way home this could be a
multiversal variant who is recruited by
Miguel O'Hara before that happened or
maybe someone who ended up multiversely
entangled with him and the others in
like appointing Crossfire or something
like that we know that Miguel has built
some kind of architecture to bridge the
spider-verse together in a you know
maybe some amoral maybe even an evil
plot that deliberately excludes miles
according to Lord and Miller miles is
kind of like the high school kid
crashing the college party he's in a
conflict with all of them except this
one Spider-Man that looks like Tom
Holland is one of the few who when you
look closely he's not chasing or
pouncing on Miles he's just kind of
watching it all go down two questions I
think we should address here one does a
quick vocal Cameo by Tom Holland amount
to a full MCU crossover like does an
animated Tom Holland equate to a
live-action Tom Holland or should we
consider an animated Tom Holland a
variant what do you guys think I think
the second one because the same would
probably go for miles right if miles
appears in the MCU we wouldn't consider
that as a connection to the miles in the
animated property right it would be a
completely maybe but what if it was
played by shamik Moore that's what I'm
saying I'm like I don't think they would
address it I think Sony would be okay
with addressing it being Tom Holland and
being like yeah it's Tom Holland but I
don't think Marvel Cinematic Universe
would be okay doing it vice versa
um but that's that's that's me on a
legal background I'm like I don't know
I wanted Consulting with my lawyers the
thing is yeah after let me give me one
second no okay so I'm back no but I
think I I also think there are no legal
is a big deal but how are you gonna have
this Citadel this giant place of spideys
and not have the Tom Holland one in that
in that Miss if it's this one I feel
like he's there he has to be there so
that's why I'm like it is him I'll say
it I'll say it is him I'll leave this oh
go out okay oh wow that is okay
um I have I don't know I have a feeling
that this there's a good chance that
this could be the the PS4 Spider-Man
um because the uh the suit looks very
much like the PS4 Spider-Man it has the
the white hands in like the long white
uh Spider-Man background I mean
Spider-Man logo on the back
um but like but to answer your question
actually like I think that there is a
huge possibility that we are going to
see
um Tom Holland in the animated
spider-verse movies
um at some point in this movie but like
they have to include like they have to
narrow iteratively be like okay this is
the same Tom Holland from the MCU coming
from
um coming from the MCU to the animated
spider verse and like have there be like
a maybe a live action scene like going
to to animated sort of like I don't know
space Jammy it's like well we're going
to the Looney Tunes World
um but like I think that if that were to
happen they would they would literally
be like hey everybody it's happening
rather than having be like an extra in
the background
um because I have a feeling that
like I don't know like I have a feeling
that Tom Holland Spider-Man does not
exist in this spider-verse and that he
is an anomaly in the MCU Multiverse
because we remember from uh from uh uh
Multiverse Madness
um American shamba says I've never heard
of Spider-Man like I've been hopping
around and like I don't know Spider-Man
in this Multiverse so like maybe like
web out of his butt like with his [ __ ]
webs out of his butt like when he poops
um this is toilet clog uh that'd be a
real problem uh but no I think that it's
something weird going on with like the
web of life and Destiny with Tom Holland
and like we're gonna see him probably
more so and Beyond the spider verse than
anything and he'll probably show up as a
little tease at the end and be like hey
it's me and my mates
um Andrew and Toby And I'm coming in
from the live action ums I'm using my
British accent
his accent will show up in this one it's
so this likes me straight up Tom Holland
not Tom Holland's Peter Parker
oh does that work can you be like this I
think Tom Holland is like a movie star
that's actually Spiderman and the
animated Sony it could work it can work
for sure it could totally work we're
willing to accept anything I mean
so yeah and I'm definitely prepared to
accept that seeing a an animated form of
Peter Parker as Tom Holland's appearance
in in across the spite of her says like
okay we just bridged with the MCU I mean
in ways we kind of already have but I
just think like this is what's hard
about it is the the numerical
designations so before in uh across the
spider or an into the spider-verse they
stay true to the comics you know 1610
that's the ultimates universe that's
miles's Universe they 616 is uh the
original like that's the Peter Parker of
that Universe uh the Earth 65 that's
Gwen Stacy's so they they stay
consistent with the correct numerical
designations Multiverse of Madness
changed all that though by saying that
the live action MCU is 616. so that's
what kind of makes it difficult I don't
I don't it's hard to imagine the
Animated Universe being the same
universe I think it's like an
interpretation it must be some other
side of it so it's kind of hard to say
that they are all connected in that same
way I think they're going to have to
have some other logic but you know to
give credit to the Sony verse they have
done a better job they've done a better
job with the Multiverse than the MCU has
I think the MCU has been a little sloppy
explaining how the Multiverse works and
inconsistent I think Loki did a good job
I think Multiverse Madness did a good
job in a completely different way I
think what if did a great job in its own
way and none of it has been consistent
overall in my it's hard because it's
they're I mean they have a million
properties touching it where the Sony is
just like it's just Spider-Man it's just
Spider-Man no one else is touching it
yet like we have uh freaking Michael
Keaton showing up at morbius but that's
it like that's as close as we're gonna
get so it's hard when you have so many
properties different writers different
approaches I mean I understand grabbing
all the writers from Rick and Morty
seems like the best idea but it's also
like they were still different human
beings on different platforms that are
just like this is our level of knowledge
for the Multiverse
um but I mean that's just my hope for
for quantumania for uh Kang Dynasty is
like so far we've had like you need a
good vocal character and in Marvel
Comics that vocal character was
Spider-Man Spider-Man was like like one
of the biggest multiversal characters
this is the most popular character so it
just kind of made sense uh and then we
got this great logic of things like the
web of life and Destiny interactive
frequency and all that great stuff
um but with uh the MCU the vocal
characters have changed we had the vocal
character of Loki and Sylvie and then
that shifted to be like he who remains
Kang uh we had the Poco character The
Watcher and what if and what the
Multiverse looked like from him was a
completely different perspective and
then Multiverse Madness of vocal
character was like Wanda and strange in
the sorcerers who had things like
dreamwalking to explain how the
Multiverse worked so all these things I
think worked distinctly in their own
stories we just didn't have like a
master plan yet and I'm hoping that
going forward in Phase five like Kang
will do these this thing that like in uh
what was it in Skyfall or inspector how
like he's like I was the author of all
of your pain and I want Kang to be like
to explain when that person said this is
what the Multiverse worked and this
character said this is how it worked
it's all just like a different
interpretation of my gospel and my
gospel is the is a sacred constant truth
so listen to me
I mean he kind of does that he kind of
does that it kind of does and Loki that
entire mom it was like completely like I
made everything ever I know how
everything goes I know what you're gonna
say after I say what I'm about to say I
am God I think he said that I think he
said a line I am Jesus uh take upon me
the body of Christ uh he did he totally
did the Last Supper we don't talk about
that enough but he did no yeah yeah I
think you're right Jess he did it in
Loki and he had a lot of people so look
it's just you know there's that weird
subsection of like MCU fans who don't
really buy things that happen on Disney
Plus shows as like a hundred percent can
like unless it happens in a theatrical
film uh it doesn't have as much weight
to in our eyes no we don't believe that
I think things that happen in Loki are
more important things that happen in
like you know eternals or you know or in
Thor 11 Thunder it's interesting that
people would think like that but I guess
it's like Disney plus is this they bring
in the new characters while the movies
are just continuing the storyline line
of older characters so it's like maybe
they're like oh these are just
introductions but it's like those
introductions are very important like no
movie is very important she released
Kang so you got anything yeah no I feel
like I'm very interested to see the
perspective of someone who never watched
One Division but watched Multiverse of
Madness and like being like yo what
happened to Wanda who are these kids
like what is going on like they would be
so lost like I feel like Multiverse of
Madness was the first movie to be like
uh catch up uh Disney plus is sort of
required now for you to fully get
um the story here same with kind of what
if too because it was like all those
extra characters for the Illuminati or
not the Illuminati yeah yes the
Illuminati yes the Illinois yeah I'm
trying to think like yeah I'm imagining
my alternate self watching uh endgame uh
and going straight into Multiverse and
Madness because you do have that like
Darkness from wand at the end of end
game like you took everything from me
like ready to kill Thanos she has that
moment with Hawkeye where she's like I
hope they'd be proud of me you know but
like she doesn't have kids yet yeah and
there's no West View yet so yeah people
do and they also don't mention Vision
whatsoever in in Multiverse of Madness
they don't like well I think they're
like you he died I had a husband and he
died yeah and then quickly move on you'd
also be like how does she get the dark
hold
exactly so she grabbed that book there's
so many gaps that you need Phil from one
division to understand Madness so like I
feel like Marvel Studios now is just
like you have to like Disney plus is
sort of like a must well
um do you think that quantumania and
Kang Dynasty won't make sense without
having seen Loki I think that
um Quantum media might just be a really
good like hey here's Kang the because
like this it's a it's a sort of formal
introduction to Kang so I think that
it'll be it won't be necessary but like
I think that there will definitely be
allusions to Loki and like why he got
released and that will like sort of like
poke people towards the Loki Direction
especially since season two was on the
way
um portal Mania is going to be the
excellent like hey go watch season one
and get ready for season two sort of
commercial for for Loki that way yeah so
obsessed yeah agree with the idea that
another Kang put that King into the
quantum realm as like a bad kid that I'm
like yeah we have to talk about it we
have to talk about that there's a
stronger King that was like get in here
like I'm just I need you to get away
from me yeah I'm I I still think that
the the quantumania Kang is not the big
statue Kang
I I think that we're going to be dealing
with multiple Kings here um I think that
there's also and like I I think I might
be doing this for rogue Theory
um there's a chance that we might see
Kang
um at the end of across the spiderverse
potentially
um because we we know that like the MCU
was going Multiverse route and like the
in that uh Lord Miller sort of hinted at
a crossover with the MCU eventually in
past interviews but like they've not 100
said yes but they're like anything's
possible with the spider verse am I
right
um so I think that um there's a
possibility here that our minds could be
blown with a Kang show and I'd be like
hey guys War's going on Multiverse War
um everything's uh Tom Holland's coming
get ready for beyond the spider verse
that'd be really fun well before we
continue thank you to Helix sleep for
sponsoring this episode across every
spider-verse sleep is so important and
here at new rock stars We Trust Helix to
protect our sleep with the best
mattresses in the world world I have a
helix mattress Mt does producer Zach
producer John think they also got Helix
mattresses we're a helix uh sleepers
here a new rock stars uh Helix sleep has
a quiz that takes just two minutes to
complete matches your body type and your
sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you everybody's unique and
Helix knows that so they have several
different mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium and fur mattresses
matches is great for cooling you down if
you sleep hot matches is great for
spinal alignment prevent morning aches
and pains even a helix plus mattress or
plus size sleepers producer Zach took
the Helix quiz and he was matched to the
midnight Luxe mattress because he's a
side sleeper and needed a softer
mattress and now he doesn't wake up with
a sore shoulder or neck like he used to
with the other mattresses that he's have
so just go to helixsleep.com inside
Marvel take their two-minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life they have a 10 year
warranty and you get to try it out for
100 nights risk-free Helix is offering
up to 200 off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com inside Marvel we also
want to thank Bluetooth for sponsoring
this episode the holidays may be all
about the red and green but this year
why not add a little blue to that
Bluetooth is a unique online service
that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra and Cialis but in
chewable tablets and at a fraction of
the cost you can take them anytime day
or night so you can plan ahead or be
ready for whenever an opportunity arises
the process is simple you sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive a
prescription within days and it's all
done online so no visits to the doctor's
office no awkward conversations no
waiting to line the pharmacy Bluetooth
tablets are made in the USA and prepared
and shipped direct to your door in a
discrete package sometimes it takes a
little more than mistletoe to make the
holidays more romantic and Bluetooth is
here to help there so if you could
benefit from some extra confidence when
it's time to perform chew it and do it
have better sex and we've got a special
deal for our listeners try Bluetooth
free when you use our promo code Marvel
at checkout just pay the five dollars in
shipping that's bluetooth.com promo code
Marvel to receive your first month free
visit bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information we thank
Bluetooth for sponsoring this episode
okay getting back to the question of
perhaps Tom Holland Peter Parker showing
up and across the spider-verse and what
his relationship will be with Miles
Morales do we think there will be
friends or foes in this movie like do
you guys think there's a way for these
two to be in Conflict without us seeing
either one of them as a villain but just
like two different Heroes who are
struggling to accomplish some kind of
selfish ambition or goal of theirs it's
so interesting because Tom Holland's it
feels like Tom Holland's not like the
other Peter Parkers which is hard to say
because it's like he is but I think him
and miles are much closer than they like
they think and I think they're gonna get
closer with
possibly Rio dying
um so I think that there they would be
friends and I think that if that image
was Tom Holland I think he's like why
are we attacking this guy again like can
I get more Exposition I think after the
last movie especially he's like uh I'm
not gonna attack first and ask questions
later I'm gonna ask questions first and
then attack
um so I think he's he's become smarter
no like for sure I think that um the
events of no way home like if this is um
um like Tom Allen Peter Parker in the
trailer the events of no way home would
be a really good reason why he would he
would take pause to attacking Miles
Morales because like he too was chased
by doctor strange and like from from
doing what he thought was the right
thing so um I think it'd be really cool
for for uh Peter Parker be like let's
hear this kid out because I've been in a
simple situation myself
um I I think that'd be a really good uh
character growth
um for for Peter I guess let's be real
here if like Tom Holland's Peter Parker
or start attacking Miles Morales I think
all of us would be like
dude right
dude some Spider-Man Lotus
yeah
sorry that was really bad no no it's
like yeah
like we love my like dude just be fret
like what the what's wrong with you
that's the thing that's the reason we
would start going back through all
everything Peter Barker said and be like
hmm right
that's why I think they're afraid of
losing where that safe little Zone that
safe haven I think Miles being there is
like literally I said this yesterday
like he and I don't know Anatomy I don't
know how bodies work but it's something
like the T cells are attacking germs and
trying to help you so it's like I feel
like that's what we're gonna kind of get
and that's kind of what we saw with like
the neurons that look we're in that
super computer I'm like if this is a
body they're attacking the foreign agent
and I think that foreign agent is Miles
and so unless they're just trying to
protect their home you know what I'm
saying like you know like ants will jump
a bird if it's attacking an ant hill I
don't know if that's true but I feel
like it has happened before in Bug's
Life so I think that's what it's gonna
look like I think that's what it's gonna
be
I mean is it it look we're late in an
inside Marvel episode right now so I can
bring this up all the you know all the
[ __ ] will probably stop watching are
we seeing nimbyism right now in in the
spider Force are they all saying like
hmm a black kid moved in yeah
well that's the thing is like not to be
horrible I'm like you also have your
mangaverse Spiderman over there there's
a lot of diverse Spider-Man in this
[ __ ] world how are you gonna keep
attacking only this one POC
back on
him and Gwen straight up pull up no mask
on the first time being a Spider-Man
hide your identity they're like it's
true I'm safe you never know there could
be a J Jonah Jameson Spider-Man yes some
of those Spiderman swinging around in
the background have white masks that are
pointed at the top be careful I Easter
egg spotted each one of them
unmasked each one like yeah we know who
you are
me she was a racist oh my God you know
if Aunt May was racist the whole time
that would be she had a shotgun when she
opened the door Woody why do you need
that hey hey
she shot Uncle Aaron she's like get off
my roof
[Laughter]
shut up and she said he's up there
she said let me do it Fisk
oh Aunt Karen you disappointed us
we thought we knew you
well we have to we got to leave it there
for this episode inside Marvel I think
we have to I don't think we can go any
further with this well you can follow
Jessica at Lulu underscore Glenn man you
can follow MTN Master taymin hey be sure
again to watch all these videos on the
channel I'm so amazed by the work
everyone is doing I love that we that we
were able to do this together I feel
like we're whipping each other up uh by
doing this it was a lot of fun anyway
you can follow me at EA boss you can uh
subscribe to new rockstars And subscribe
to inside Marvel wherever you get your
podcasts uh thank you all so much for
watching and uh we'll see you next
peace out